so what can we expect from the weekend
speech joining us now with more former
senior adviser to the trump campaign
whose name is mentioned quite often as a
potential senate candidate from the
great state of
north carolina her home state laura
trump is with us good to see you laura
thanks for being back
you got it thanks for having me it's so
unfair that i start out that way isn't
it because
i know for a fact there are a lot of top
republican leaders
in north carolina that are not just
talking about it but they're making a
lot of outreach
is it something you'd leave open for now
without asking a question just leave the
idea open in your mind
oh absolutely look i i've taken it very
seriously and
i have no decision to announce live here
on sean hannity tonight but um
i will i'll tell you to stay tuned
because it is certainly something that i
would be honored to do so
i am keeping it open absolutely i would
predict you'd win all right
so the president coming out speaking at
cpac
look what has happened in a month
foreign policy
executive orders no legislation
amnesty at the borders every i mean
straight on down the line a direct
contrast
to everything that president trump did
now
i would imagine i think i know the
president pretty well
that he will be highlighting i told you
so
this is what you can expect thoughts
yeah well he absolutely will and he did
tell you so
a lot of us tried to tell the american
people that this would happen
if joe biden became president of the
united states i think the speed
at which so much has happened has really
kind of shocked people to be honest but
you're right i think for the first time
in a long time americans found that
under president donald trump
they had somebody they felt like was
actually fighting for them and standing
up for them and fighting for america
and joe biden has made it very clear not
only through his actions
but through what he has said that it is
no longer america first we know he just
told the folks of the g7
america first is out well who wants a
president
that doesn't put their own country first
it's it's absolutely ridiculous
but then you see the open border policy
then you see the fact that he supports a
bill to give amnesty to 11 million
illegal immigrants people that are
illegal here in our country
wants to give them citizenship it's it's
really frightening to see i think the
speed again at which
all of this has happened but you can bet
that president donald trump is going to
talk about it i'm sure we'll hear about
china i'm sure
we'll hear about iran the the paris
climate deal
you know so many things that so quickly
have turned around and really have been
incredibly detrimental to the future of
america
so i'm excited to hear from him this
weekend i think it's going to be a great
speech
i know he's excited to speak to
everybody there at cpac you know
when you look at the the one issue we're
in the middle of a pandemic
the biden administration when they
took office there were a million shots
going into people's arms every single
day
a lot of these democratic governors
screwed that up then you look at
yeah what's happening the position he's
taken in the middle east and around the
world
america last but the callousness of just
with the stroke of a pen
getting rid of high-paying career jobs
while simultaneously making us dependent
on foreign energy sources
to me is the worst thing because we're
the we're now going to have all these
illegal immigrants
and we're going to have people out of
work for the pandemic competing with now
out of work
energy sector uh workers with with very
specific skills
yeah it's it's so outrageous uh day one
executive order eliminating the the
keystone xl pipeline
uh putting 11 000 americans out of work
on day one for joe biden and
don't forget under donald trump for the
first time in history we were a net
energy exporter we were energy
independent and we actually
exported energy and aside from all the
jobs that brought to america from a
national security standpoint
it meant that we weren't reliant on the
middle east on russia for
anything we did it all here at home
and to see that that joe biden again
like you said with the stroke of a pen
got rid of all the good that donald
trump did
especially within the energy sector i
think it's been incredibly disappointing
to people but
you know this is something again during
the campaign that you heard donald trump
talk about
scranton joe was not going to do a good
job for the energy workers in his home
state as he claims of pennsylvania
and here uh you know day one he got rid
of uh so many of these jobs
and i think sean sadly it's only the
beginning i think there's going to be
more
uh more disappointment for so many
people under a biden presidency
yeah sort of the the make russia make
the iranian muellers make middle eastern
countries that hate us
uh and china rich again america lasts
scary times
laura trump thank you